It's time, ladies and women, to get your DAB on.
Because you guys have been straight up been thugging up some sick thicc beats...
...sisters.
Girl what you've been cooking is straight up in LIT!
Okay, last week I asked you to...
I had a shitty file of music, I basically recorded for five minutes and I asked you guys to mix it
to something... hella... flammin.
[laughs]
So let's see how you guys performed!
[upbeat]
♫ Respect the wamen everybody
- Oh!
- Yeah!
♫ Respect the wamen everybody
♫ Everybody. Everybody. Everybody. Everybody.
- Oh! Oh! Oh!
♫ Break it- break it- break it down
[beat drops]
♫ Wamen
- Boy!
Woo!
♫ Break it- break it- break now girl now [scream]
[laughs]
That's pretty good, that's preeetty good 'Aditya Shrestha'
♫ My name is Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin'
♫ Yes I can't rap and no, I'm not from Compton
♫ England is my city, and you know I'm retarded
[laughs]
♫ And you know I'm retarded
Yeah!
♫ Is math related to science? [Wooah!] Is math related to science? Is math related to science?
♫ Is math related to science though?
'This is- this shit hella LIIIT!'
I didn't expect different genres and shit.
Usually it's all like, fucking dance and shit.
Fucking heavy rock or whatever it's called, I don't know.
Okay great.
♫ Scare PewDiePie, Scare PewDiePie CANNED!
♫ But I still got paid anyway, but I still got paid anyway!
[laughs]
♫ Scare PewDiePie, Scare PewDiePie CANNED!
♫ But I still got paid anyway, but I still got paid anyway!
♫ Goddamn I'm so disappointed.
♫ Am I guilty... of the same crimes?
♫ I don't spend money on anything, I've got my computer.
- Got a very anime feel to it.
♫ Maya is like our budget dog because she only has one eye
♫ This is gonna be the most boring life of, boring life of...
♫ ... the rich life
- ... PewDiePie
♫ Scare PewDiePie, Scare PewDiePie CANNED!
- You gotta rhyme perfectly, what the fu- [laughs]
♫ But I still got paid anyway, but I still got paid anyway!
♫ Scare PewDiePie, Scare PewDiePie CANNED!
- [joins in] I still got paid anyway!
That's fucking good.
Endigo also respects women so much that he looks like one.
That's impressive.
♫ Respect... hh-wamen
♫ Respect wa-
♫ Respect wamen
♫ Respect, respect the wamen everybody
- Maybe I should have spent a little more time on the vocals
♫ 'What the fuck are you doing?' Respecting wamen
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
- Oh!
♫ You can't kill me, no my channel never dies (PewDiePie sucks!)
♫ No more ideas, no original content
♫ But when I fuck your mom, you know it's with consent
♫ So welcome to the family, I'm your daddy now bitch (so slutty)
♫ I'll make 'You laugh, you lose' 'til I'm filthy fucking rich (you laugh, you lose!)
♫ They call me nazi since the day of my fucking birth
♫ Ohhhh! Ugh
♫ Waait a minute... who ARE you?
♫ I'm PewDiePie the greatest mother flipping guy [oh!] my balls will drop dipping in your eye
[laughs] The flow is so off.
So yeah if you guys didn't see this, "Lushsux" actually painted a tweet with my picture on it
He asked me for a selfie so I sent him the one from last week's submission
and he actually put it up in a museum in Vienna!
It's pretty good, if you're in Vienna you should check it out.
Thanks again Lushsux, that fills my ego to have my head that big, it really helps a lot, thank you.
"PewDiePie is a chi"- [laughs]
♫ PewDiePie!
Hey don't show that!
♫ It's everyday bro!
♫ PewDiePie is a child rapist
- Oh!
♫ PewDiePie-Pie is a child rapist
♫ PewDiePie is a child rapist
- Hell yeah!
♫ Everybody knows that Nick Crompton is the greatest
- Oh!
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
♫ You can't kill me, no my channel never dies
♫ Everybody knows that Nick Crompton is the greatest
♫ My name is Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin'
♫ Yes I can't rap and no, I'm not from Compton
♫ England is my city and you know I'm retarded
That was good, that was good shit man.
[bad recorder playing and drum beat]
♫ We're talking away
♫ I don't know what to say, I'll say it anyway
- Wow
♫ Today's another day to find you
- Oh
♫ Shying away, I'll be coming for your love okay?
- That's...
♫ Take on me [recorder and trumpet picks up]
- Wow, incredible. Yeah.
♫ Take on me!
♫ Taaake meee onnn! (Take on me!)
- The talent is er...
♫ I'll be gone
♫ In a day or TWOOOOOO [recorder screeches]
- Okay, okay
- Okay alright, that was really good, I'm really proud of you guys!
♫ My name is Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin'
♫ Yes I can't rap and no, I'm not from Compton
- [joins in] Yes I can't rap. Boyyy!
♫ England is my city and you know I'm retarded
♫ (E-E-E-England is my city and you know I'm retarded)
♫ Is math related to science?
- WOO!
[Felix claps along]
♫ Is math related to science?
- Whaaaa!
- Oh! OH!
♫ Is math related to science though?
♫ Do you believe in reincarnation?
♫ It's everyday bro!
Okay, that was pretty tight man.
Pretty- pretty lit I would say.
Very well done. Well done.
♫ Chika-chika break it down now girl [screams]
♫ [loud blaring music]
- [burps] Woah! Ah... Okay!
♫ Is math related to science though?
♫ [blaring music continues] Wibba!
♫ [slim shady beat] Respect wamen
♫ Respect wha- respect wamen
♫ Respect, respect
- Is this Eminem?
♫ Respect the wamen everybody
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
♫ You can't kill e, no my channel never dies
- Ey!
♫ No more ideas, no original content
♫ But when I fuck your mom, you know it's with consent
♫ So welcome to the family, I'm your daddy now bitch
♫ I'll make 'You laugh, you lose' 'til I'm filthy fucking rich
- Ey!
♫ Called me nazi since the day of my fucking birth bitch
♫ And I just dropped some new merch and it's selling like a God church
- Hell yeah! [joins in] God church! Yee!
♫ So welcome to the family, I'm your daddy now bitch, your daddy now bitch, your daddy now bitch!
- Hell yeah!
That's pretty fucking good, I really like that one. Well done.
♫ PewDiePie, the greatest motherflippin' guy
♫ My balls will drop dipping in your eye
♫ Disrespecting women, no thanks, bye
♫ PewDiePie, the greatest motherflippin' guy
- Oh shit!
- Hell yeah!
♫ My balls will drop dipping in your eye
♫ Disrespecting women, no thanks, bye
♫ And I just dropped some new merch and it's selling like a God church
- Hell yeah
♫ Chika-chika break it down now girl now
[screaming becomes the beat drop]
This is getting really fucking good!
♫ Are you paying attention?
♫ Today's theme is...
♫ Respect wamen
♫ Respect respect respect wamen, respect wamen, respect wamen
- Wow
- The lyrics is incredible!
♫ Respect respect respect wamen, respect wamen, respect wamen
Always good shit from Day By Dave
♫ You know, they're clearly taking my name and shoving it into the ground
♫ just to get more clicks on their shitty fucking website
- "Fuck the mainstream media"
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
- Yeah!
♫ You can't kill me, no my channel never dies
♫ No more ideas, no original content
♫ But when I fuck your mom, you know it's with consent
♫ So welcome to the family, I'm your daddy now bitch
♫ I'll make 'You laugh, you lose' 'til I'm filthy fucking rich!
♫ They called me nazi since my fucking birth
♫ The greatest... motherflippin'... guy
♫ Taaaake onnn meeee (take on me!)
- Woah! Shit dawg!
♫ (taaaake meeee onnnn!)
♫ I'm still here, I'm still making videos.
♫ Nice try Wall Street Journal, try again motherfuckers
Hella tight. Hella tight, we only have 3 left bros!
Boiii!
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
♫ You can't kill me, no my channel never dies
♫ No more ideas, no original content
♫ But when I fuck your mom, you know it's with consent
♫ So welcome to the family, I'm your daddy now bitch
♫ I'll make 'You laugh, you lose' 'til I'm filthy fucking rich
♫ They call me a nazi since the day of my fucking birth
♫ But I just dropped some new merch and it's selling like a [blurs away]
♫ Fuck you! [smooth music]
♫ This is smooth as fuck!
♫ Hh-wamen!
♫ Taaake meeee onnn!
- I legit like this, this is fucking dope!
♫ Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff!
Aaaand it's ruined, I'm just kidding [laughs]
♫ It's everyday NIBBA! It's everyday WIBBA!
♫ My name is Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin'
♫ Yes I can't rap and no, I'm not from Compton
♫ England is my city and you know I'm retarded
♫ Everybody knows that Nick Crompton is the greatest
♫ PewDiePie the greatest motherflippin' guy
♫ My balls will drop dipping in your eye
♫ Disrespecting women, no thanks, bye
♫ PewDiePie the greatest flippin' guy
♫ Respect hh-wamen!
♫ Respect wha- respect wamen
♫ Respect... respect 'em
♫ Respect the wamen everybody
♫ My name a-Jeff
[laughs]
Ahh Grandayy, appreciate it man. Good shit.
I've heard this song before, it's fucking good.
It's really fucking good, like I listen to this unironically.
It's made by a French YouTuber.
♫ Nibba!
♫ Nibba
♫ Wibba
♫ Plebba
♫ It's everyday bro!
♫ Chika-chika break it down
♫ Welcome to the ShitTube it's ya boy, PewDiePie
♫ You can't kill me, no my channel never dies
♫ No more ideas, no original content
♫ But when I fuck your mom, you know it's with consent
♫ PewDiePie the greatest motherflippin' guy-guy-guy
♫ Is math related to science? (related to science?)
- It's fucking good! PewDieTrap man, hell yeah.
♫ Just science bitch, yes it is bitch (yes it is bitch)
♫ Is math related to science? (related to science)
♫ Respect wamen. Respect wha-
♫ Respect wamen. Respect... respect 'em
♫ Respect wamen. Respect respect the wamen everybody
- I get emotional everytime I think about it.
♫ My name a-Jeff. My name a-Jeffff! My name a-Jeff!
- It's so good! It's so fucking good!
♫ My name a-Jeff, my name a-Jeff!
♫ Jeff, Jeff, Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff!
Jeff Jeff Jefffff! [gun clicks]
Is math related to science? (related to science?)
♫ Just science bitch, yes it is bitch
I love it, so fucking good!
Seriously everyone who submitted, if yours' didn't make it I'm sorry.
I can't show them all but legit so much fun, I love doing these.
I hope you guys enjoyed. I hope you hh-wamen enjoyed as well.
For next week, I want you to post a title and a picture with clickbait, okay?
The most clickbait thing you can come up with, PewDiePie related. Good luck.
You're basically doing all my work from now on, that's what's happening.
The most meme-tastic ones will be previewed in the next episode of Fridays With PewDiePie!
But that's it for now!
Thank you bros so mu- I mean thank you sisters so much!
Love you guys!
buy all my merch